ja fast sechs monate krieg in der
ukraine und wir wollen anfangen mit ganz
aktuellen bilder die uns heute morgen
erreicht haben nämlich von letzter nacht
wir sehen hier mitten in der nacht große
explosionen hier am horizont und danach
ein feuer was hier tobt das ist erstmal
sehr dunkel deshalb versuche ich das
ganze zu erklären was wir gesehen haben
ist die brennende die neckarbrücke eine
brücke die die ukraine in den letzte der
den er brender erhält durch das land
geht und der eben auch das russisch
besetzte gebiet in der mitte teilt hier
unten in der region persson dort
versucht die ukraine nämlich eine
gegenoffensive zu starten und hat diese
brücken heute nacht hier bei person und
bei novak hofft nochmals bombardiert die
hoffnung ist dass man dort den
russischen abzug den deutsch-russischen
nachschub nördlich des turnierplan
abschneiden kann und eben eine
gegenoffensive zu fahren um nördlich
dieses flusses zumindest die gebiete
zurückzuerobern dazu wie gesagt heute
nacht neue angriffe der ukraine mit eben
mit diesen high maßsystem mit diesen
amerikanischen 70 kilometer reichweite
schweren raketensystem das sind die eine
sache die man sich angucken müssen wir
müssen aber auch auf den osten koopmann
im osten des landes gehen die schweren
kämpfe weiter und dort haben wir es auch
im letzten hand immer wieder gesagt
nutzt russland wirklich alles was das
sowjet also mal her gibt unter anderem
auch diese aufnahmen haben wir hier
gesehen hier erstmal einen drohen staat
auch die russen nutzen mittlerweile ganz
kleine drohnen quadrocopter um ihre
artillerie zu überprüfen und hier sehen
wir eine ukrainische brücke unter dieser
brücke sind soldaten das heißt dass eine
position der ukraine die hier gehalten
wird um die front zu halten und weil
diese brücke sich sozusagen nicht
bewegen kann und die soldaten sich auch
nicht bewegen können ist es für die
rosen relativ einfach die anzugreifen
und genau das tun wir auch tun sie auch
wir sehen dass hier mit mit diesem
geschützt und das hier und das ist das
besondere ist ein
1955 gebaut ist panzer abwehr geschützt
weil sie eigentlich genommen wird und
panzer abzuwehren mt 12 papiere heißt
das aber weil die russen ihm genau
wissen wo die ukraine sind die ukrainer
können sich nicht wegbewegen kann man
dieses schütz geschützt auch nutzen um
eben feindliche und in jedem fall
ukrainische wir sehen uns jetzt hier
positionen anzugreifen wir sehen also
hier die einschläge direkt unter der
brücke weil die ukraine kommen einfach
nicht weg und weil die ukraine hat nicht
die möglichkeit kriegen diese risiken
geschützt und die russischen positionen
nur zwei bis drei kilometer vorhinein
zugreifen können russen das weiterhin so
machen dass also von der russischen
seite die waffen genutzt wenn die
ukrainer setzten stattdessen wir haben
es immer wieder gesagt auf hightech auf
neue waffen und ganz neues und diese
diese aufnahmen hier von der l 119 die
jetzt aus großbritannien eingetroffen
ist ein relativ leichter artillerie die
aber auch schnell auf- und abgebaut
werden kann 36 stück davon lieferte
großbritannien und das sind die ersten
aufnahmen wir sehen es hier wie die im
einsatz und wir sind also hier zwei
dieser geschütze die er aufgebaut sind
und hier abgefeuert werden und die
ukrainer bedienen die die schießen damit
wie gesagt 36 stück sollen sie bekommen
haben und danach und das ist ganz
spannend werden die jetzt mit dem
berühmten stroh das stroh was japanische
flagge des gelb unter dem blau sehen
werden die mit dem stroh zugedeckt in
der hoffnung dass hier russische drohnen
sie nicht von oben sehen können so also
jetzt die l 119 zum ersten mal im
einsatz aber die ukraine haben nur sehr
wenig davon ich hab gesagt 36 dass er
bauen die ukraine weiterhin so was hier
das ist do it yourself das sind wirklich
selbst gemachte raketen-abschussrampen
auf ganz normalen jeeps wir sehen uns
hier und darauf werden gebaut es acht
raketenwerfer ist acht raketenwerfer die
von abgeschossenen oder beschlagnahmen
russischen hubschraubern und auch eigene
hubschrauber die nicht mehr fliegen
abgebaut wurden wir sehen uns hier und
diese s8 werfer werden eingenommen um
eigentlich eigentlich sind sie dafür
geworfen vom von der luft auf dem boden
zu schießen aber hier werden sie
genommen und vom boden auf dem boden zu
schießen weil die ukraine eben nichts
anderes haben die brauchen weiter an
dieser raketen die brauchen weiterhin
irgendetwas mit denen sie schießen
können und so nehmen sie eben genau das
hier zum schluss wollen wir uns angucken
nochmal die befreiten gebiete das hier
ganz neue aufnahmen aus der stadt sie
wäre und ich möchte es hier einfach noch
mal kurz festhalten wir sehen hier noch
mal diese kreuze also überall am
straßenrand an kreuzungen sind die
kreuze von den getöteten menschen hier
sie wären jetzt 100.000 einwohner bis
vor etwa einem monat dann befreit von
der russischen armee und wir sehen hier
wirklich ein trauerspiel so sind die
gebiete aus da haben wir raten frau
gesehen die an einer pfütze versucht
sich wasser zu holen das sind die
gebiete die russland kontrolliert das
ist es was der ukraine droht wenn sie
aufgibt wenn sie sich dem russischen
aggressor hier sozusagen ja er gibt das
droht ihr das droht den städten insofern
braucht die ukraine weiterhin unsere
unterstützung
sich weiter zu verteidigen
[Musik]